[Music]
the dawn of 2021's almost upon us and in
the face of the uncertainties of the new
year we at least have anime to keep us
entertained
if you're one of the people still
looking for something to watch in the
upcoming season then i've got a treat
for you today today we're going through
10 of the most anticipated new anime
this winter 2021. perhaps i can help you
get started with your to watch list
with this list perhaps you can find
something to recommend to your best
friends and buddies i don't want to keep
you waiting anymore
so let's get to it
starting off things we take a look at
back arrow back arrow is an interesting
show
it's the next tv anime for the code
geass director and it's an anime
original mecca series set to premiere
this january you also get these big
names joining the party like people
involved in series such as kill la kill
and magi
as for its story well it's set in a
world surrounded by walls
giving it protection the war pretty much
serves as the god that serves as the
foundation of ringo rindo however things
change when some amnestic guy named back
arrow appears in the outskirts claiming
that he's come from beyond the wall
thus he heads out to fight to restore
his memories oh and by the way
this protagonist is voiced by yuki gagi
doesn't that remind you of something i'm
pretty sure that the last few people who
still do so would have stopped putting
stock on big names being attached to a
project ever since the glorious mess
that is gbh but
i'm not gonna lie back arrow looks
pretty cool would it cause the
resurgence of the mecca genre back into
the mainstream
i mean i personally doubt it but it
would probably be a cool underrated show
to follow
[Music]
holding up for you if you've been
absolutely hooked to it i present to you
an ample follow-up
243 saiyan high school boys volleyball
club this is a volleyball anime centered
on gimichika hajima
moving back to his hometown after some
troubles in a tokyo volleyball club he
finds himself reunited with his
childhood friend yuni kuroba
turns out that him and said childhood
friend form the perfect volleyball duo
together they enroll in saying hi
and with the duo's entry the school's
volleyball club breaks out and begins
the journey to be the next big thing in
town
in contrast to what we've come to expect
from our sports anime this one seems to
be more relaxed and serious the manga is
officially listed as a jose series and
you can expect the hype action sequences
to take a backseat to more drama and
character development that's not to say
that the show's not exciting it's just
that it's got a different
approach to a sports anime and if you
like that kind of approach then
this could be the show for you
[Music]
let's move on to the next one now low
tier character tomozaki kun
life is a game such a common statement
and such a good example of a phrase you
can slap onto your light novel hero to
make him seem
smart i'll start today fumia tomozaki is
one such character
one of the best gamers in japan dom
ozaki finds himself doing what gamer
protagonists do
think of the rules and boundaries of
real life as the worst possible thing
no clear-cut routes to victory horrible
balance so irrational
all in a bad game zero out of ten
however some other person thinks the
opposite and surprise surprise
it's a fellow gamer in the form of
everyone's idol konami perhaps this
girl's cracked the code moving on and
getting ahead in life and she intends to
teach domozaki every bit of it yep it's
one of those life coaching light novel
adaptations with a brooding unsociable
protagonist
i'm not sure what i can really compare
it to for a one-on-one comparison but it
certainly gives us some strong snafu
vibes
expect a lot of comedic routines whipped
with a dash of drama in this tale of
self-development and growth
we proceed with redo of healer let me
ask you a question
when it comes to rpg classes which is
the most powerful one
could it perhaps be the healer the one
who has control over who gets to live or
not i mean i personally agree and it's
not
just because i like playing cleric
characters in tabletop campaigns guess
what
it's open season again for revenge
titles and following the trail that
shield hero broke open onto the
mainstream
is redo of healer so after being
exploited again and again by others
gyaru finds out the true potential of
the gila class
problem is he gets it too little too
late and he can only lament what could
have been
not giving up is for losers and kyaru
decides to cast healing magic on the
world in order to move everything back
four years into the past armed with
newfound knowledge of his potential he
sets off to redo
everything and become the strongest
being in the universe i already
mentioned that redo of healer is a
revenge title like shield hero but what
i forgot to mention a while ago is the
fearless prediction that this would be
the popcorn anime of the season
popcorn not in the sense that it's to
turn your brains off entertainment
although that counts but more of how
it's going to be the talk of the town
for all the controversies it's probably
even more edgier than ari feretta and
shield hero combined that's quite
something
everyone's at the edge of their seats
looking to see how this series will
unfold in january
skate the infinity comes in next on our
list come to think of it we haven't had
an anime about skating right
well now we do in this series we follow
reiki a skater who finds himself
knee-deep in the latest craze in town
the addictive and extreme sport
s the sport isn't for the faint-hearted
for it's such a dangerous activity
that it has to be kept a secret with its
explosive battles that come along with
the races finding a new prospect in the
form of unassuming transfer student
langa
reiki decides to take him into the world
of extreme sports despite the former
having no
skateboarding experience what awaits the
duo in this thrilling and dangerous
world of
s skate the infinity sure comes with a
very interesting and unique premise that
i'm sure the most common anime fans can
find engaging
given that it's being done by bones i
expect nothing but top notch quality out
of this anime original series
make sure to give this a shot when the
new season rolls around
netflix presents our next entry on the
list highrise invasion
now here's an anime that i've personally
been looking forward to having binged
the manga because i enjoyed it so much
now what is highrise invasion about
imagine being issaquid out of nowhere
but instead of landing in a generic jrpg
land number 31245
you find yourself in a world of
skyscrapers oh and everyone's out to
kill you too and they're all wearing
these creepy smiling masks it's a death
game of survival and you've got nothing
but your wits to help you
such is the plight of yuri honjo who
finds herself in such a tense
predicament
seeing a brutal murder in front of you
isn't the best welcome to this new world
but carrying the goal of finding her
lost brother here yuri resolves to not
give up and survive the maddening realm
now as i've said i've read the manga and
i think this is one of the better
survival series out there and is way
overdue for an anime adaptation
i loved how it juggles genres and does
some shifts from survival to full-on
battle shonen and if you're a fan of
such shows and want a cute girl leading
the charge make sure to check out high
rise invasion
next in line is kimono gian the time's
ripe for a supernatural action series
and joining the freight is kimono gn a
new rising star courtesy of jump
sq for those keeping track it's where
some beloved series like seraph of the
end and moriarty the patriot came to be
when dead animals mysteriously start
appearing in a village
who do you call top supernatural
specialist gohachi in ogami of course
however he arrives to the scene not to
find the culprit behind it all but a boy
named gabane who befriends him working
together to solve the case the two may
have become the perfect combination
but garbane might not be who he seems at
first glance
it seems that jujitsu kaizen had opened
up the floodgates to the resurgence of
the jump supernatural action series and
i'll be very much looking forward to
kimono gm if the current feedback on the
source material is anything to go by
this one is gonna be a treat to see
as we move on to the top three it's time
to start bringing back the isa guys in
with so i'm a spider so what we've seen
someone reincarnated into a slime
already so why not a spider
reaching godhood as isakai leads have
done before is probably easier as a
spider than starting off as slime
right well not quite for one our
protagonist here has to fight for
survival because when you're a lowly
spider that everyone can't seem to wait
to squish
the difficulty of it all gets turned up
to 11. our protagonist here would need
every bit of luck and determination in
order to make it out alive but luckily
that's exactly what she has thus the
journey to become the strongest spider
in a fantasy world begins the hit like
novel has been getting quite a lot of
traction and it's about time that we
finally get a nice anime adaptation to
introduce
newcomers to this interesting world i
found the story to be quite engaging
and i can see why it gets quite the hype
that it's got and taking a look at the
first few episodes might answer your
questions on why it's so
[Laughter]
our second most anticipated news show of
winter 2021 is to no one's surprise
mushoku tensei between the two isekai
titles on the list
well three if you count high-rise
invasion i doubt that there's anything
that can eclipse the hype for mushoko
tensei as far as this season is
concerned the series has gone out and
earned a lot of goodwill from its fan
base the very same fan base that can't
wait to see one of their favorite light
novels being brought to life in the form
of an anime adaptation
mushoku tensei starts off with the
isakai thing you know the drill and
shoots its protagonist into the new
world in the form of a kid the thing is
we know that in stories like this the
human child is probably
the most powerful being carrying modern
day genius in the form that has
limitless potential for growth
knights and magic already taught us this
thus as the newly christened rudeous
greyrat our protagonist begins his
journey to conquer this world while
getting over some regrets carried over
from his past life
overall it's an interesting series that
prides itself on its characters and
setting
if you're curious as to why everyone's
going crazy over mushoku tensei maybe
putting this on your to watch list can
help do the trick
despite the power of the isakai train
the number one hype show this upcoming
season has to be something in a
completely different genre
it's horimia they say the opposites
attract but i beg to differ a
relationship wherein two people
are just so different just doesn't work
out in my opinion i think that a more
accurate way to go about that statement
is to instead turn the focus on two
people who complement each other and
that's exactly what we get in this much
awaited rom-com horimia i wouldn't say
that brooding izumi and upbeat yoko are
complete opposites but a chance meeting
leads them to opening up to one another
knowing each other's hidden sides we
then see that they're actually pretty
damn good compliments to each other this
is the story of a blooming relationship
that revolves around two people knowing
more and completing
each other and it comes with its fair
share of twists and turns it's funny
right isn't it at first glance horimio
seems quite plain and generic for a
rom-com and admittedly i had those
sentiments until i read the source
material
trust me this isn't your everyday
rom-com and the two characters just have
such
a good chemistry that i couldn't stop
reading in terms of hype and scope of
people watching it well i don't think
that anything compares to it i'm pretty
positive that horimia will carry that
positive momentum for a great finish
once this season is done
now with that i'm done with this list i
want to know yours what do you think
would be the biggest hit of the season
how about a sleeper hit you know there's
nothing more that i like than engaging
in conversation with you don't forget to
leave a comment before you leave oh and
please don't forget to give a like and
subscribe too
that's got to do it for now see you next
[Music]
[Music]
time
[Music]
you